على اعتاب سن ال 50 يطمحوا شغل بلاي جودا
الى طي الصفحه وهذه الصفحه هي هذا المشهد
الذي يخاطب فيه بحماسه الاف المناصرين في
عام 2011 اثناء الازمه التي هزت كوت
ديفوار واسفرت عن مقتل اكثر من 3000 شخص
حينها كان وزيرا للرئيس لورونج باكبول
الذي رفض الاعتراف بهزيمته امام منافسه
الحسن وترى خلال الانتخابات الرئاسيه
للشارع اسس في عام 2002 حركه الوطنيون
الشباب المواليه للكبار
لكن بعد اربع سنوات اتهامته الامم المتحده
بممارسه العنف وجمدت امواله و املاكه في
الخارج
2011 فرر الى غانا قبل ان يتم توقيفه في
عام 2013 بعد امر توقيف دولي صادر من
محكمه الجنايات الدوليه
القضاء بتهمي ارتكاب جرائم ضد الانسانيه
في عام 2021 برات محكمه الجنايات الدوليه
كل من
الذي عاد في السادس والعشرين من نوفمبر
الجاري الى كوت ديفوار مؤكدا انه يسعى
للاعب دور سياسي لكن في اطار ما يسميه بلم
الشمل
والمصالحه الوطنيه